[Music]
you slept through the morning show
you didn't see see and you haven't
bothered to start your mythic quest
i hear it's good though but since your
iphone crapped out on you and
every new one comes with a free year of
apple tv plus you might as well check
out
ted lasso prepare for a show that feels
like it was based on a dead joke about
the two types of football
but was actually based on a series of
nbc sports commercials
how many countries are in this country
four but unlike the geico caveman show
that
yes really happened you haven't dabbled
seriously don't
don't do that this show overcame
impossible odds
to actually be really good it's at least
as unlikely as leicester city winning
the premier league in 16.
i just got asked to be the head coach at
lochester
whoa get ready for 10 episodes crammed
full of hugging
learning growing crying
and more hugging and because streaming
services are cheaper than therapy
we're working through all of our trauma
by watching tv comedies
even the cartoons so gear up for a
season-long motivational speech
delivered by the world's first manic
pixie dream dad who's here to change
lives
and shoot you in the face with a fully
loaded pun gun for 30 minutes straight
and our goal is to go out like willie
nelson on a high you know what you do
with tough cookies don't you
nah dip and milk and they met at his
friday night chess club apparently they
liked each other's moves
oh that wasn't a joke was it all i guess
it kind of was
meet ted he's what happens when a golden
retriever humps a motivational poster
until ned flanders pops out
knock-a-doodle-doo and he's up against
the only force
powerful enough to counter that much
optimism
british people
thrill as every type of cynical brit
falls to his toxic positivity
that's a long time to wait ted and
relentless food-based assaults
i'll start bringing these to you every
morning called biscuits with the boss
hey
man you guys gonna be chinchin well we
know you haven't been home in a while so
we thought we'd bring some home to you
i'm good in a story that shows how even
though the british words for certain
things may be different they don't say
out of bounds
they say into touch they call fleets
boots i have never coached the sport
that
you folks call football we still have a
lot of gaffer
going out to the pitch grass here to
watch practice
training fries called chips chips are
called crisps
and bangers aren't great songs we still
have cookies
or as you all call them here biscuits
right what's the billiard game y'all do
that sounds like a brand of cookies
snooker that's it and am i getting notes
of axe body spray i think they call it
something else here
what does that mean we still ain't
nobody here gonna kiss their sister
which is an american phrase that i'm now
realizing does not exist here i mean
come on y'all it's 20 points let's just
call them cigarettes
what's a wanker okay we get it different
countries have different slang
that right there's another example of
how our english and y'all's english
sometimes do not jive it's not that
funny
oh dang it i've gone to make coach sad
can't stand to see him like that
like a puppy dog locked out of the
sausage factory sorry coach
are you ready for some football no good
cause neither is this show because the
soccer gets about as much air time as
the day job's on friends
here we go and there you go
i mean come on players aren't even
sweaty at halftime
and while ted lasso may start out as a
dope who can't tell a striker from a
scouser
by the end he'll still be proudly
ignorant about the sport he's paid to
coach
bring me how that's all sides well no
i'm serious how's that offside i
understand it yet
and oh through co-spy on charm while
everyone else does the work
ted really is american oh no offense
coach
dang i feel so bad making fun of this
guy it's like came mr rogers pickup
truck
surrounding ted is a major league full
of side characters
perhaps because the show has the same
exact plot as the film major league
like rebecca the team owner you'll be
ashamed you didn't recognize sooner
[Applause]
higgins the sub to her dom keely
a character who's early similar to jason
siddique's new girlfriend
that's awkward coach beard every king of
the hill character combined into one guy
the only two players who get any
character development a parade of barely
recognized footballers who we can only
assume had their lives changed by 10 off
camera
and 8. your favorite little introvert
since ted and scrubs
man bill lawrence is so good at making
lovably weak characters we can all laugh
at
colin isaac please stop he's such a wimp
oh didn't realize you heard that my bad
coach so cuddle up for the right show
at the right time because we all just
craved some positivity in an otherwise
terrible year
and nothing heals our fractured psyche
like a southern fried alpha male
football coach
who's also a worldly musical loving
feminist who always knows the exact
right thing to say
yeah that's a thing i'd hate to see you
and michelle obama arm wrestle but i
wouldn't be able to take my eyes off it
either even though if you met a person
who acted like ted in real life you
would probably assume they're a serial
killer
and you'd be 100 right
oh i'm sorry coach i take it back i
believe in you
i just need someone to believe in me
starring the snuggly american
the beautiful shame shame shame
coach beard that's it that's his actual
name
the water boy tosh spice
assistant to the regional owner harry
styles
david belland lean street hooligans
making a good point mvp yeah it is
ah see there you go
[Music]
yes yes and when someone walks into the
room and you're totally not watching
porn
hey how are you excuse me miss watson
hey boss hello
cornballers
[Music]
don't worry england ted says success
isn't about the wins and losses
it's about helping these young fellas be
the best versions of themselves on and
off the field
it's coming home it's coming home
football's coming home it's not
coming home keep your enemies close
and a loaded gun closer i'm a little
teacup
short and stout here is my handle here
is my spout